you guys would you get like 214
nominations what was it like yes 212 yes
I have something crazy absolutely have
you kind of got is it out of your system
or do you still feel the pull of the
show is it is it weird no it's it's this
is so much fun you know I haven't seen a
lot of the gang flow along since the
premiere so now we get to hang out and
obviously it's one of the last arrays
but it's it's the icing on the cake by
the way I think you could have rocked
this talks on the show I love this it
tell me the inspiration behind it's I
don't know it's golden it's told you
qivana it's yes know what this is think
about gold right yes but I what I love
is that it's gold to amigo exactly yeah
did you take anything from the set when
you left or did were they like David and
those guys you said I want to know if
Dan and David let you're stealing
oh no no no I'm sure all that stuff is
in a vault somewhere traveling the world
now in some exhibition and any advice
for the people that are now in the
prequel enjoy it Joe and I know they're
shooting in Northern Ireland and it's a
wonderful place just have fun I heard it
was rainy and cold though - that's ooh I
heard esra
okay any nerves any nerves no no no this
is all good this is just funny it's a
little hot but it's just fun damn it
good luck go out there and go get your
this Emmy gold
[Music]
[Applause]
you